Finally, it's always a good question whether assertions, in production code,
should remain enabled or not.
Here are some points to consider. First, failing is better than bad data.
If your program fails with an assertion, you know that there's an error.
If it simply produces a bad result without actually checking it,
then this may have far worse consequences than failing.
Second, the more active assertions there are, the easier it is for you to find the defect.
Third, defects in the field are hard to track,
which means an assertion gives you a chance to find the defect before it goes into the field,
in particular, in combination with thorough testing.
And even in the field, if assertion are still enabled,
you still have a far better chance to find defects because,
well, you get the failure rather than producing bad data.
On the detractor side, so what speaks against assertions being enabled in production code?
We have performance, performance, performance.
If you do have a large data structure with lots of global checks and leave this enabled,
performance will suffer.
However, there is large number of assertions which impact performance only in a marginal way.
Checking some result is larger or equal than zero, ranges, like things.
This will not impact performance in a measurable way.
The answer here is to first leave the assertions on
then measure which assertions actually do impact performance
and possibly do turn this off and leave the others enabled.
The second thing is asssertions, when they fail, typically caused the program to crash,
or at least, aboard execution immediately.
This is not very user friendly.
You should give your users a chance to recover
even if an assertion finds that something has gone wrong.
But, then again, if your program crashes because of a failing assertion, what's the alternative?
The alternative is to keep on working with bad data
and bad data can produce arbitrary and even worse results later.